i'm the homicide lieutenant with the las
vegas metropolitan police department
i'm out here this evening to brief you
on a homicide investigation that we are
conducting in the 5500 block of west
charleston
the details that i have right now are
preliminary but at around 2pm we
responded to a report of multiple shots
fired at the car wash directly behind me
a hispanic male in his early 40s was
suffering from multiple gunshot wounds
he was transported to university medical
center where he was pronounced deceased
what we have learned at this point is
that the victim
was at the car wash vacuuming his car
with his wife
he entered the car and was sitting down
in the driver's seat when an
unknown vehicle pulled up next to him
a person or person's inside the vehicle
fired multiple shots
into the car striking and killing him
that vehicle then fled the scene
we have detectives out here interviewing
there was approximately a dozen
witnesses at the car wash that we are
interviewing right now we're also in the
process of canvassing for surveillance
video
and seeking out any additional witnesses
i urge anybody who was at the car wash
that is
did not stay behind that saw anything to
please reach out to crime stoppers
you can do it anonymously or you can
also reach out to homicide at lvmpd.com
so with that i will take a couple
questions but again still very early on
in the investigation
right now we believe there is a
relationship between the suspect and the
deceased
uh i'm still not putting that out at
this point but we do believe there is a
relationship and it is not a random
incident
so right now it's still too early for me
i we have conflicting stories as far as
the suspect vehicle so until i have that
a little more dialed in
we're again with it throughout the
evening we should have a little bit
further on that
once we have our surveillance people our
surveillance video
crew out here to recover some of that
hopefully we can piece that together
throughout the evening
the wife was not injured we're in the
process of interviewing her right now
she was in the passenger seat of the car
when the gunshots were being fired into
the car
doesn't appear to be no all right
right now until the coroner does the
examination
i i don't know the specifics of where he
shot he sustained multiple gunshot
wounds and was just pronounced deceased
at the hospital
and the surveillance is right there at
the uh what did you call it again
the car wash behind me
again it's still early on in the
investigation we have detectives that
are canvassing for video so once we have
the video and we're able to look we'll
be able to
answer that a little further all right
thank you guys
thank you you got to speak up i can't
hear you
the his it's a hispanic male he's in his
early 40s as the deceased
all right yes thank you